so what does it take to succeed on
youtube this year in this conversation
with two successful youtubers we're
going to be learning 10 different
secrets really that they wish they knew
when they started their channel we have
dr andrea who has her silver play button
she's going to be breaking down
everything she has learned that can help
you go further faster growing your
channel and then we also have larry
chung with a financial channel who grew
to a thousand subscribers in just 10
days and 53 000 subscribers in six
months and so so much powerful content
is coming up uh but today's video is
streaming inside of actually a challenge
we're doing but also on our think media
podcast channel and on my fan page on
youtube and it's brought to you by
ourtube1kchallenge.com if you're a part
of the challenge shout me out let me
know what have you been loving so far
but there's actually still some time to
join and if you go to tube 1k
challenge.com it's entirely free it's
five days seven sessions and we actually
have the replays available to watch as
well and so there's still time to get in
if you haven't taken advantage of that
yet so you can see the url on screen and
then if you happen to be watching this
on the replay take advantage of time
codes on the youtube
chapters that will help you get through
this content but we're going to get
straight into this
10 different tips and strategies and i
want to welcome our guests today first
we have dr andrea she's a physician in
toronto canada and dr andrea tell us a
little bit about what you do
and when did you start youtube and how
has your journey been on youtube briefly
yeah thank you first of all thank you so
much for inviting me to be here i'm
super excited
well i am a physician in toronto here i
am a pain specialist so i treat people
who have chronic pain
and
in 2019 i decided to post some videos
for my own patients to
amplify a little bit my clinic because a
lot of what i do
in chronic pain management is educating
patients so i decided to start recording
i still record with my iphone
and
i record here in this room in my home
and
what i decided to do i could post only
one video a month is basically what i
teach my patients in the clinic
and um
and then i i started talking and they
loved it i was posting one video a month
until december 2020
and then in 2021 i
joined vra and the
vra is the program that you offer i
joined after a challenge a one week
challenge
in may 2021
and i already had 80 000 subscribers at
that time
and then it has grown a lot and now i
have 330 000 subscribers on my channel
wow 330 000 now your journey's been
incredible and i can't wait to get into
your tips in just a second but
one of the tools we use uh called vidiq
i can see that you just got 1.7 million
views
in the last 28 days 16 000 new
subscribers so i'm excited to learn from
you
but we also have larry chung with us
today and uh larry
you've been on youtube for a while now
you're a chartered financial analyst
tell us a little bit about what you do
and also um how long you've been on
youtube and what the journey's been like
sure absolutely so my name's larry and
it's you know thanks for having me here
sean um so i'm a chartered financial
analyst and i'm an i'm an educational
entrepreneur and prior to covid you know
i had an in-person you know education
center you know teaching you know
mathematics and english and then covet
changed everything
and absolutely you know turned my
business into an online program which
which has been really awesome and so
believe it or not i've i've been
following sean since 2019 and at the
time i was
um you know thinking about youtube but i
i didn't pull the trigger and in 2020
you know covet you know changed my
business
and i was thinking you know should i
should i really move online into like a
different space into a different niche
and and finally in 2021
um i i watched uh sean's i think it was
his uh youtube challenge again and at
that point i realized i have to adapt i
have to change so in april
of 2021 i started a youtube channel on
finance which is my professional
background in investments and you know
since then i've been you know producing
value-added content investment research
and following the the vra system that
sean teaches in this program and it's
been absolutely incredible and i've been
on youtube for about uh eight nine
months now
i've connected with a lot of people it's
allowed me to really help a lot of you
know of my viewers in investments and
it's been a great journey so far so
thank you
wow thank you larry so much for that and
we're actually going to kick it off with
point number one and we have 10 points
today that we kind of have prepared uh
ahead of time from your stories and you
can expound on these but larry you
talked about how patience is a virtue
when it comes to youtube what do you
mean by that
yeah absolutely so i would say that
youtube is a very high variance kind of
business and when i say high variance it
means
the effort that you put in and the
output that you get out the the outcomes
could range like incredibly large and
sometimes you might post a video that
you put a lot of effort into and you
know the outcome might not be that great
but other times you might put not as
much effort into a video and have that
video do really well so one of the
things that i took away from sean's
program that was very helpful was really
looking at the data understanding what
it is that your audience is interested
in and then really adding value in that
area and taking the time and the patient
having the patience to review your data
to know what went right what went wrong
will ultimately you know make you a more
successful youtuber but i i really do
think that patience is a big part of the
journey on youtube because the variance
can be very large
yeah i love that and dr andrea you mean
you've been on the platform now since
2019
um and you're a busy professional you've
got stuff to do in life and of course we
all do
how have you had to
allocate the time um to create youtube
content and especially in those early
days stick to it when you were just
getting started creating your first
videos and what have you learned about
the need of patience
oh my god yeah a lot
that's why in the beginning the first 18
months almost three years i was able to
post only once a month because i was
doing everything
and then january 2021 that's when i made
a commitment to post one video a week
and
that's also when i started monetizing
believe it or not i did not know about
monetization i had 20 000 subscribers
in january 2021 and i still had not
monetized if it was not for a friend of
mine
who told me that um
youtube was going to put ads on my
videos if i wanted or not because i did
not want ads on my videos i said these
are my patients i don't want them to be
watching ads but when i discovered that
youtube was going to force ads i said
okay so then i signed with adsense in
january 2021 when i already had 20 000
subscribers but patience was so that
helped me to hire some people hire help
i hired my son
he's the editor of my videos now and
that's why i'm able to post more but
it's extremely frustrating when you put
a lot of efforts to do one video and you
get very little very few views so i
agree with larry
sometimes the effort you put it's not
correlated with the amount of views and
then you have one video that just
explodes
i love it well tip number two is choose
a clear channel topic and theme
uh dr andrea you said that keeping a
clear niche and sticking to it really
helps the algorithm what have you
learned about that when it comes to your
channel
yeah it's interesting i i think i i had
to study so much from youtube and when i
see that funnel right
i didn't understand exactly what it
meant because my videos my
the views from my channel and i already
had uh
25 million views
and i only posted 84 videos in my
channel so far
so
of all those 25 million views 96
come from youtube recommendations
and i did not understand why my my
videos were not uh ranking high on
search like only four percent of all of
these views come from search and i
thought that there was a problem with me
until i discovered that that's a good
thing
and uh which means that youtube is
promoting my videos to everyone
and i think that is a reflex of me
understanding the audience so this is
extremely important if you understand
who is the person watching your video
you're going to make the videos for them
so i know the people with chronic pain
they are women more than men
and older women so i try to make videos
that you know please that kind of
audience and they have pain and i speak
in a language that in late terms
i try not to speak any complicated
medical term and i i think they like
that because i understand this is the
patient population that come to my pain
clinic anyways
you know one of the things i love that
you said said there is that you're just
so focused on your patients and we
really like to talk about the creator
who understands the viewer best and
really serves the viewer best wins
and you want to help them and speak
their language we call that kitchen
table talk what is the way when we title
our videos the words we say in our
videos are they
talking to peers who would understand
insider language are they talking to
everyday people and if you're watching
this i think that could be a really
powerful way to really connect who's the
person you're serving speak their
language and connect with them you know
tip number three here is youtube is
different than other social media
platforms and larry i'm curious um why
did you want to go all in on youtube
when there's opportunity to do other
platforms maybe you have an approach to
social media as a whole
but what is it about youtube that made
you really want to invest your time
especially as someone who really
understands investment
yeah that's a great question there's a
lot of people who talk about investments
on instagram or tick tock but when we
think about the way people consume
information tick tock is short form
information and youtube is long form
information you know as someone who
really wants to share deep value i i
find it challenging for me to
demonstrate what i know in short form
content on on tick tock and i'm not sure
instagram is the best medium for me to
express my views on the market so
youtube allows me to really share my
thoughts uh with this long form content
and because of its recommendation system
and because youtube serves as like a
track record for the
views and opinions that i've shared over
time it's just a much better place for
me
and my niche compared to compared to
tick tock although i do know a lot of
people can find success in those areas i
personally like to share long-form
content which i find more valuable to my
audience
i love that and dr andrea you mentioned
that youtube is very different than
other social media platforms and you had
to learn a new science youtube ology
talk about your experience
with uh yeah
oh my god yeah i had to learn so much
about youtube like i am a scientist and
i publish scientific papers i do a lot
of statistics and understanding the
analytics is not easy so youtubology for
me you know understanding
not just editing videos but how does
youtube work what uh you know what makes
a good thumbnail what makes a good
script i script all my videos and i use
a teleprompter
what uh how do you promote your videos
before after you you record them but uh
i think for me was what is very
different i am on twitter for a long
time and i had facebook but what i find
is that um
youtube nurtures the creators they
really give a lot of
training for us there is a lot of
materials that helps you to be
successful and i never found this on
twitter on facebook and i joined
instagram recently
but um i find that youtube really values
creator i i just watch it this morning
um
susan the ceo of youtube and she values
health information she values education
she wants to double the amount of
education on youtube and that's exactly
what i'm doing health education on
youtube so i feel nurtured
i feel protected like even when there
are hate comments i feel that there is a
way that i can youtube values me and
wants to make my mental health
succeed so i'm not
burning out on youtube which i don't
feel in any other platform
i love that and if you're just joining
we're talking about ten lessons
that successful creators wish they knew
when they were starting and the next one
number four
is the importance of good titles and
thumbnails being crucial to your success
and so larry
uh this was a point you mentioned talk a
little bit about your process and coming
up with a good title a good thumbnail
and some of the things you've learned
yeah absolutely so when i think about
when i think about youtube and i think
about my relationship with viewers when
you first are on the platform
and you first start out nobody knows
who you are and so you attract people to
view your content through a couple
variables the first is the thumbnail the
second is the title and then the third
is the topic so when i think about how
do i get someone to engage in my content
i have to make sure that i'm positioning
my thumbnail and my title and delivering
on the promise of you know what what i
say that title and thumbnail will be so
because those are the only things that
new viewers will learn about you you
have to do whatever you can to make
those two areas
uh i guess distinguished from whatever
else is on the home recommendation page
yeah it's so important and really a
lifelong skill to continue to develop
what will get attention and what will um
really grab your audience's attention
you mentioned it's not really though
just title and and thumbnail but even
topic and i think one of the big uh keys
to the success of your channel from my
point of view is you're talking about
topics that people really care about
talk about that um what is your
feelings of staying in touch or
understanding your audience and how do
you come up with what type of videos to
make next
yeah
so that's something that i put a lot of
thought into when i first started my
channel it was very investments based it
was very equity research stock selection
based because those are areas that
people have a very strong gravitation
towards
and as i build more of an audience on
youtube i also try to introduce content
where i can connect with viewers more
meaning telling personal stories about
my career and sharing lessons about uh
setbacks that i've had so i think when
someone first starts out i i do think
that they need to really deliver on a
topic that a viewer really wants to know
right away no one's really interested in
you know someone's personal story when
you first you know get to know each
other but as you
build your channel there are content
pieces that i've
purposely set aside to just really build
ethos with my audience to really build
trust because i don't want my content to
be 100 investments based when you do
that um it really i would say silos your
channel so that people will only want to
watch you for x and so over time
i will talk about investments of course
but i will talk about not just real live
market events but also investor
education that's a little bit more
evergreen and also
um topics related to career so that
people can engage with me on a personal
level and not just come to my channel
for the knowledge that i'm sharing
strong now if you're getting value out
of this smash the like button and i'm
excited because tip number five is
respect your audience and build trust
now this is something that a lot of
people haven't don't really talk about
and so i'm so excited to unpack this dr
andrea will start with you
um
you said this with influence comes
greater responsibility i love the weight
of that but it also seems kind of heavy
what's your what's your thoughts with
that in terms of your approach to your
youtube channel and really respecting
your audience and building trust
well sean that's the most important
thing for me
i am a physician and i treat people who
have chronic pain
and
people who watch my videos they are
suffering from chronic pain or they know
someone who is suffering
and i read every single comment because
i approve every single comment before
they go public i don't let anyone
my comments are battled by me
unfortunately i don't have time to
answer every comment but i read
everything so
really the stories that i hear
are people suffering from pain and um
on the other side there is a person that
is a real person it's not just a viewer
and
they tell me their stories and and i
know how to help them
but i can't provide medical advice via
social media via youtube so i have a cut
and paste response which is this channel
is for educational purposes talk to your
doctor i can't offer you medical advice
but there has been situations that i i
read a story and i still can remember
and i cried after i
i wrote that response
i cried
and because i knew how to help that
person and i couldn't because of the
professional you know i can't just give
advice via youtube
so the person i remember this man from
africa his his wife had had a stroke
and she had a shoulder pain
and she was trying to do the exercise
that i show in my video one of my
viral videos that has 4.4 million views
and he recorded her and he sent to me
via facebook
and i knew she was doing the exercise
wrong because that was not exercise for
her and i had to respond to him saying
sorry i can't help your wife and then i
was sobbing after i said that
and then i told him
i'm going to make a video for your wife
and then i did i did a video uh for
shoulder pain after stroke and then i
sent to him and then he sent to me a
video of her doing the right exercises
so that's why i do this youtube channel
because i want to help people and uh
he's in africa
i in my hospital where i work here i
only have the four walls and i can help
so many people even here in toronto i
can't help everyone who has pain here
so that trust that people having me some
people a lot of people write to me come
and say
you are the only hope that i have there
is nobody here to help us
uh we are following your advice that you
write in youtube and um
and we are getting better my thing is
getting better so
there's no no money tag no price that
pays that so i'm really happy and
satisfied
with the success of my channel because
of this i'm doing what i i love doing
most which is helping people
wow i mean i'm getting chills as you're
talking and that's just so i think i can
see in the comments how much that's
impacting people because of course we're
trying to you know make a living and
grow our channels but ultimately
especially at think media we're on a
mission to help purpose-driven content
creators and i just love the mission
you're on and the fact that even just
one life can be changed one person's
health could be impacted one person's
finances could be impacted in terms of
how larry's helping people it's just
amazing and we're gonna stay on this
number five of uh respect your audience
and build trust because larry you really
talk about the importance of eventually
people are gonna remember your name and
really it's kind of a bigger level of
building a brand building trust share
some of your thoughts in regards to tip
number five
absolutely yeah i'm happy to so you know
over the course of uh you know producing
content on my channel i actually have a
lot of people add me on linkedin
and instagram and they send me direct
messages letting me know
um how much my content has helped them
understand this topic specifically when
i talk about more
complicated things like macroeconomic
you know circumstances like inflation
which is a which is an issue that a lot
of people have to face today not just in
the us but but worldwide so when i think
about
what i do and you know that aligns with
what you just said being a like
purpose-driven channel
um
i think that people remember
who the creator is beyond just the title
the thumbnail and the topic so
i think that sometimes
when you know people are only focusing
on uh producing i would say
transactional value content um there
they might potentially be missing the
bigger picture to build like a deeper
relationship with you know an audience
um i'll give you an example a lot of
people
because they found value in my work they
were commenting in the comment section
larry when are you going to you know
start a patreon larry when are you going
to for example like
help people outside of youtube and i
actually
purposely waited until i reached the 50
000 subscriber like benchmark before i
did any real monetization and the re and
the reason is
i i don't want people to think that uh
my youtube channel is only to
make money it's not you can see that a
lot of the content that i do is very
focused on in much on investor education
it's very much focused on helping people
become better equity analysts to
understand the stock market and so
because people like they found that kind
of uh connection genuine when i did
start patreon um the reception was was
incredible and like so many people
joined without me really needing to do
much
marketing at all
and so when i think about um everything
that i've learned in my youtube journey
including everything that i've learned
from vra which has been very valuable
yes the topic's important yes the
thumbnail and the title is important but
if a creator isn't trusted in the broad
scheme of things it can actually hurt
someone because if the if a lot of
people and people are generally smart
when we think about like the broader
population
what ends up happening is if they
remember that person's name even if that
topic is interesting
you know the audience will like actively
try to not watch that person's content
and i think that's like the next level
of what i'm trying to achieve on youtube
yes
uh topic's important and i want to
continue producing more of that but i
want to produce content where people are
excited
to see when i produce content i want to
produce content in the future where when
people see my name they want to
immediately like learn from what i have
to share
well that's so strong you know it
actually kind of reminds me there's a
proverb that says a good name is to be
chosen rather than great riches and it
makes me think that man the brand the
trust you're building um just as a
deeper level than being transactional as
you said and so this is some weighty
wisdom but i i wrote down a quote when
we were doing our uh you know pre-talk
for this session and you also said this
don't be scared to be vulnerable the
more you show your character the more
memorable you will be and you've kind of
touched on that but i'm interested in
this idea of vulnerability what does
that mean for you in terms of being
vulnerable in your videos
yeah so
when i think about my channel topic it's
very much
macro economics investment research
portfolio strategy it's very
i would say business oriented and for me
to share personal stories of of setbacks
that i have encountered along my career
that's an example of being vulnerable
not because i think it will attract
views and not because
um you know i i want to like garner
attention it's because i want to
actually have in like a candid
conversation with my audience and when
you have a real conversation with
friends and family it's not just
business and it's not just
like
like content for that specific topic
it's also how you're feeling things that
you go through uh that like you don't
normally like you know that you might
feel uncomfortable sharing but it brings
people closer together and so that's an
aspect of you know vulnerability that i
think creators once they get to certain
stages in their journey
it would be beneficial to really help
your audience know who you are building
that ethos building that relationship
strong number
six is
there is more to youtube than just
uploading
videos and so we're going through 10
secrets that uh
we wish we knew when starting youtube dr
andrea you said
you want to invest time before and after
each upload and that time that you
invest pays off later so what are some
things you do that it doesn't just
include
filming the video or uploading the video
yeah and i wish i knew that before
um it's a lot of time uh preparing the
video is what takes me most of my time
sean it's a
i research a lot even though it's what i
teach my patients i i study a lot and
i'm learning a lot about the topic
because i read articles and i go read
books and i watch other videos and then
i write my script in the beginning i was
so scared because i asked some of my
colleagues to read my script make sure
that everything i was saying was correct
now i don't have time anymore to do that
sometimes i do but um
i spent hours and hours and hours
writing exactly word by word what i want
to say to make sure that the meaning is
what i want to transmit to my patients
to my audience
and so that's what takes time recording
is quick uploading is quick but then
afterwards
then i say okay who is going to see this
video so i then i have to post on my
other social media i post on instagram i
create cards and then i post on linkedin
and then twitter and facebook and then i
spend the whole week promoting and
answering comments about that video that
i just uploaded
i make an effort to answer all the
videos that i uploaded that week
and then i can't answer comments from
past videos anymore there are too many
but uh it's a lot of work it's uh it
takes me a lot of hours to prepare
before and after
and i love you know that you're of
course we're sharing our answers and
we're sharing what it really is
you know youtube is definitely a
commitment there's so many rewards and
there can be accolades and growth and
behind dr andrea's the silver play
button and of course the impact you make
and even what it can lead to in terms of
revenue
but at the same time there's something
about putting your heart uh into this
and your time and i know what's true
about dr andrea and larry and what we
also commit to at think media is we also
spend a lot of time studying it's
studying the platform studying blogs
reading i buy books i want to study
business online marketing courses all
these different things because all of
that
input it's hard to give out of being
empty and that's why when you invest in
yourself and you keep learning and
leveling up your content gets richer
because you've distilled down all that
information so i love just hearing about
all the before and after work that uh it
takes and really this is the real talk
hit like if you've been getting value
and i'd love to hear your aha moment so
far from this training we've covered the
first six tips out of ten but number
seven is add value first
monetize
second so larry
you mentioned a little bit about
eventually when you launch your patreon
but expound on this point a little bit
yeah absolutely so
my philosophy in in business in general
is
you know people
before they know who you are right
they're they're they're interested in
getting value first
and so the way i approach my channel and
my content is purposely making sure
that people can walk away from every
single video having learned a lot and
having deepened their knowledge in those
areas if they want to join my inner
community that's awesome and that's
totally cool but it's very important to
be
focusing on adding value first
and then
lightly and gently okay monetizing your
work because i i think about the
creators on youtube and i follow quite a
bit and and i think that some creators
they they integrate monetization
into their content in such a beautiful
way that makes you want to not only just
support their journey but if you're
interested in their work you actively
want to you know subscribe to their
service i i do see some uh creators that
are much more for example uh using hard
sales uh in their video
and they're you know the video is much
more of like a sales pitch rather than
delivering on the promise of the title
and the thumbnail and because i know
that people will eventually remember
your name your channel your brand the
values that you stand for um i
my philosophy is that adding value first
and then
you know focusing on you know the
business second is is something that's
going to work out in the long term
i love that you know and one of our
phrases we say here at think media i
think we actually are borrowing this
from somebody else but uh your income is
directly correlated to the amount of
value you give to the marketplace and we
we just really believe too that if we
can lead with value and even especially
as a finance expert yourself
the way that money is exchanged is in
exchange for value we believe that going
out to dinner and paying fifty dollars
we're getting more value for the food
we're getting and so hopefully too on
youtube if we lead with value and i like
how you also withheld from opening your
patreon so you wanted to build trust
first i just think there's something
powerful
about serving first adding value first
of course maybe being intentional about
building a business plan but also being
patient
just kind of realizing that man if you
add enough value to the marketplace the
marketplace can't help but reciprocate
that value to you do you agree i
absolutely agree and there's something i
want to add because one of my videos
where i talked about inflation and
macroeconomics
that video
i think it got over
600 thousand views
and because it was placed on the home
page
so heavily across you know com you know
users uh screens across the world some
of my high school classmates and some of
my family members
from from asia actually saw my content
on their feed
so when i think about what i'm doing
it's not just
uh you know posting content and you know
uh
gaining subscribers and running a
business it's also about making sure
that people remember me for someone who
wants to help them first and then
there's an optionality
to you know work with me on it on a
deeper level so that's what i want to be
remembered for and that's and that's why
i purposely waited until i got to a
certain level on youtube 50 000
subscribers before i did patreon because
if if i started earlier then it's kind
of like harvesting
uh before you know the
before the
before the food is ready
man i love that so strong and that was
number seven but we're about to really
get into it now
number eight be ready
for positive and negative comments let
me know in the comments if you've ever
received a negative comment maybe you're
afraid and you go that's one of my
biggest reservations is what's going to
happen if i put my content out there
and how can i prepare for those i'm
going to start with you dr andrea
um
what is your thought in this area of
sometimes youtube comments can be a
dumpster fire i mean if we're honest you
know and you're in front of all kinds of
people especially with the kind of views
that you and larry are getting uh go
into what you mean by this tip
yeah uh the good comments
they give me energy to keep doing what
i'm doing gives me you know the
motivation
but also they can inflate your echo ego
right they can make you feel bigger than
you really are
um
and you have to be careful because we
need to keep
being humble
and don't let your egos grow too much
but the negative comments really it's
interesting
i open them i open as i said i approve
all my comments i don't let free
comments on my channel
because a lot of people are
you know disclosing personal information
sometimes people write all of their
symptoms and then they put the telephone
email so i don't approve those comments
because of confidentiality to protect
their confidentiality and privacy
but there are some hate comments
especially because i talk about opioids
a lot
you probably heard about the opioid
crisis in north america that there are a
lot of people dying of overdose of
opioids and i tell my honest opinion
about opioids they're great to treat
pain but they can kill people people can
get addicted over those people can you
know do terrible things under opioids
so then i get a lot of hate comments
i get comments of people saying that i
am incompetent that i don't know
anything that i'm talking about
that the information that i put in my
video is wrong
that i didn't do my research properly
and that can put you down you know that
can really hurt you because i say well i
think i did i think i did everything i
could
and and then you feel am i really
incompetent and
you know what um
every day before i open my comments to
read them i really pray
and i pray that god will prepare my
heart i'll say whatever it's coming in
those comments please prepare my heart
to hear if it's a good comment or bad
comment if it's good i don't want to be
too proud and if it's bad i don't want
to be depressed i will use this if i'm
wrong it could be that i'm wrong i will
do a better research and i will post a
correction in my comments i will ping a
comment or i will i will redo the video
at all
but you need to be prepared you need to
be prepared psychologically or that can
put you down and
sometimes i thought about quitting my
channel
because i thought am i doing am i doing
something wrong here are people
attacking me for what i'm saying about
pain pain management and opioids i said
no i think i still am doing right and
i'm still helping people
wow man i think that we can relate to of
course the emotions here the fear of
this coming down the road um as well as
the pain we can feel when actually we
get a negative comment it kind of
reminds me too the wisdom you just
shared of a quote that i learned from
john wooden a basketball court coach who
said you can't let praise or criticism
get to you it's a weakness to get caught
up in either one
and it's so wise of you to say i don't
want to get inflated by just reading all
the positive comments and uh be on the
roller coaster of emotion of tying my
value maybe to just the praise
nor the criticism and i think if we can
stay uh man i love that you pray to
think about let me steward both well
there's so much wisdom there uh but
larry we gotta have you in on the
conversation here i mean you talk about
how the internet could be a scary place
and you're getting thousands and
thousands and tons of almost a million
views on your channel now or maybe it's
over that
that's just so many humans on the earth
what's been your experience um with
positive and negative comments
yeah so
you know earlier when i said that
youtube is a very high variance place
it also is very high variance when it
comes to the comments section right
specifically when you're talking about
topics that people
have a very strong opinion on and as you
know investments is a place where in the
market there are so many different
opinions and there are so many different
perspectives all of which should be
respected but there are certain times
when uh you know people are going to
leave comments that might not
necessarily strike the best tone and i
guess that's you know putting it lightly
but
as a strategist on youtube
and as an investor myself i understand
that the market is full of opinions and
because the market is full of opinions i
can expect my comment section to have a
spectrum of opinions as well that some
of most of them of course are very
positive but of course there are some um
you know uh viewers who have different
opinions to share and so my my
philosophy when it comes to comments is
definitely respecting um everybody who
has a voice to share um just at the end
of the day i make sure that if people
are not necessarily um you know being
respectful then i'll definitely comment
and you know really set it straight um i
don't
tend to delete comments um i know
youtube has that feature but i do tend
to respond uh when when there are
comments in in that way just because i
think that it's a very important um
place for people to see counter
arguments and as long as the counter
argument is healthy that's great if the
counter argument is i would say making
you know attacks outside of the topic
then
then i think it's appropriate to respond
i love that you share that and and i
want to encourage if you're watching
this on the replay or
um you know
it basically comes with the territory
larry and dr andrea shared that tip
number eight is be ready for positive
and negative comments um and you're
gonna kind of get both the truth is it's
like the famous aristotle a quote if you
want to avoid criticism altogether
here's what you do
just say nothing do nothing and be
nothing the 2022 update to that is if
you want to avoid criticism just don't
put your opinion out there don't press
record and don't upload a video but if
you're going to make a difference you
actually do need to say something you do
need to take action and i think you
imagine of course maybe some negative
comments will come your way but think
about all the people that larry has
helped with his advice think about all
the people who dr andrew has helped with
her youtube videos and so there's
something about
having
soft
a soft heart but thick skin
on youtube and so that brings us to
number nine which is to think beyond
youtube
i love this because of course this is
all about how to get you know
our channels growing faster in fact
right now we're streaming this session
it's actually part of our challenge and
if you're not a part of the full
challenge we have more content like this
in a private facebook group tomorrow we
have a session with heather we have
another
creator session just like this with a
couple more guests tomorrow afternoon
but all of that's going to be happening
in our private facebook group so make
sure to register at tube1kchallenge.com
if you're interested in this kind of
content and let me know what you've
liked best so far
but even though this challenge and this
content is all about what i wish we knew
when we were starting youtube um there's
also the importance of thinking beyond
youtube and so larry
you mentioned that really youtube should
just be part of your brand portfolio
break down what that means to you and
some of your advice
sure so when i think about how people
consume information which is a fancy way
of saying how people learn people you
know learn visually they also learn from
a listening perspective and if we think
about youtube the format is videos but
some people don't necessarily like to
learn with videos some people like to
read
some people like to listen to podcasts
and so when i think about youtube and
the format that youtube provides us it's
a very powerful way to connect with our
audience with deep value with long-form
content but for those of our audience
members who want to connect with us and
see our for example like blog
things that we have to share through a
written email or through an audio
podcast youtube is a way for us to
bridge our audience with the different
kinds of content pieces that we can add
value to their lives outside of youtube
so that's something that um you know i
am going to do in 2022 to connect with
my audience on a written level because i
like to write i like to speak on camera
i like to share my thoughts on video but
i also like to write that's one of my
you know deep passions as well sharing
my thoughts and research through writing
is something that i like to do and i
know that's a very
powerful way that people learn and the
way to do that though is to build an
audience off youtube
and for me specifically it's through
an email list
and things like that
super wise there's a lot of nuggets of
tips in there that ultimately you know
youtube is a vehicle to reach other
people to serve other people but you
also it's good to diversify larry's
building an email list maybe
diversifying to other social media
platforms you could diversify into text
messages
build awareness around your website or a
blog and then what's the bigger business
what's the bigger business model or
what's the bigger even mission that you
want to accomplish
you know the crater economy is estimated
to 5x this year and creators are
building new ventures they're expanding
into
susan the ceo of youtube said that
youtube creators are building the next
generation of media companies and so
youtube can be a starting point that can
lead to so many other things which
brings us to tip number 10 and then in
just a second i want to have dr andrea
and larry share with us some final
encouraging words as well as just their
advice for getting through hard times on
youtube sticking with it and some final
thoughts
but this is interesting because i think
a lot of us we want to go viral i mean
who doesn't want a viral video who
doesn't want to like man if i just got a
viral video if i just had my moment if i
just had that video get a million views
if i just had a video break out but
larry mentioned viral videos can
actually
hurt you they might help you but they
could hurt you so you want to be careful
larry talk to us a little bit about the
caution we should have when it comes to
viral videos
yeah
and i'm glad to share my thoughts so
when i think about when i think about
a human being's progression in this
world
when they first get their first job you
know what entails in that journey they
could get a promotion right they could
get a promotion and if they get promoted
they have to serve
at a higher level they have deeper and
greater responsibility and i think about
a viral video almost as if youtube gives
you
a promotion
and when i think about my situation uh i
had a video where i talked about
inflation
and the strategy behind how to
hedge your portfolio uh because of
inflation and that video did really well
um and i'm glad i helped a lot of people
and that video elevated my channel to
the next level but
it it really in my mind i took it as a
very serious matter i i didn't just
celebrate because i'm uh this video did
really well in fact i i realized that
youtube had promoted me to a position
where i i would now need to serve people
and add even more value and if i didn't
do that
correctly and if i didn't do that in the
right way
then that viral video or that promotion
per se would would not for example be
very fruitful so i think when you get a
viral video
um you have to really make sure that the
rest of your content the quality of it
of course quality is king on youtube the
quality and the follow through of future
videos makes you want to
makes people want to continue to you
know connect with you on your journey i
mean and that's the importance i think
of a viral video because if some people
they go viral but
the subsequent videos don't really
connect with the audience at that level
then then the chat then the algorithm
might get confused and youtube is an
algorithm after all we do have to
respect the algorithm and and therefore
the channel might not for example grow
uh organically like the creator had
wanted so i think of viral videos as a
as a double-edged sword and i think of
it as a promotion if you are ready
to be on that stage
because of our viral video we'll give
you a lot more subscribers um you know
viral videos can definitely help you but
if you're not ready and you don't follow
through in the right way then i think
that
it might not be as helpful
a lot of wisdom there and it kind of
makes me think we like to say use your
season in obscurity to prepare you
for popularity you know sometimes
obscurity is a blessing sometimes your
first videos not really being seen much
uh much are great because you get to
practice in public
but you may not be ready for prime time
you're kind of just doing your
developmental years and all of us need
those whether they happen on youtube or
they happen somewhere else you didn't
become a financial expert overnight dr
andrea didn't
you